now as the binding administration
continues to issue
pink slips to thousands and thousands
and thousands of american oil and gas
workers
as part of this radical climate change
fantasy
gensake today was unable to even explain
when
where these new mysterious green energy
jobs
the millions that they're promising
would appear
not a good moment take a look when it is
and where it is that they can go
for their green job and that is
something the administration has
promised
well i'd certainly welcome you to
present your data of all the thousands
and thousands of people who
uh won't be getting a green job maybe
next time you're here you can present
that so how about this uh the laborers
international union of north america
said the keystone decision will cost
one thousand existing union jobs and ten
thousand projected construction jobs
well what mr chompaga also indicated in
the same interview was that president
biden has proposed a climate plan with
transformative investments in
infrastructure
and laid out a plan that will not only
create millions of good union jobs but
also help
tackle the climate crisis jen has a job
as does everyone else where are these
people going to get the job that work
full-time that need to put
food on their table pay the rent pay the
mortgage pay the car payment
pay insurance or the truck payment uh
and where are they going to put away
money for college and put away money
for old things like retirement meanwhile
over on capitol hill senator lindsey
graham calling out the democrats
impeachment madness
because despite no case despite no
evidence no chance of conviction
and a massive double standard democrat
democrats still want to hold
this unconstitutional sham trial with a
predetermined outcome anyway
and create yet another pointless
spectacle inside
the sewer the swamp chamber here to
explain more
south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator i know you've been
talking about the issue of of bringing
in
you know witnesses i'm in favor of it i
want this trial to go on
i want to interview chuck i want to
interview joe biden i want to interview
kamala
i want to interview pelosi i want to
interview maxine waters
i want to interview cory booker eric
holder i got a whole list
would you consider looking at my list
yeah i'll be glad to look at it but
unlike uh
you i actually have to sit there and
listen to all this
i'm hoping that's a good point i'm not
going to be watching every minute yeah
yeah
i have to yeah i got to listen to this
crap so uh i hope by sunday or monday
the trial will be over here's what i can
tell you
if the house managers want to call one
witness the defense is going to call all
the people you named and
and then some to my colleagues tomorrow
there are a hundred of us what we do
today is going to
make history for the rest of uh the time
america exists
what democrats have done is basically
declared war on the presidency itself
the impeachment in the house took place
without a hearing
without one witness being called and
without a lawyer
for the president of the united states
you can't get a traffic ticket based on
the procedures
they used to impeach president trump and
we're also impeaching a man who's out of
office
when you combine a snap impeachment with
an impeachment of a president who's out
of office
you're going to destroy the presidency
itself i know you hate trump
but please pull back before we set in
motion
the destruction of the presidency by
never ending impeachments
based on lack of depre due process and
political retribution as the motive the
pr the presiding
judge as new pointed out is a guy that
already declared that he's guilty
i mean okay i could think of a lot of
countries this reminds me of
not one of them resembles the united
states of america
that's number one now we've learned oh
if you didn't have a snap impeachment
now we know a lot of this was
pre-planned plotted scheme people
involve okay
that that they didn't know in the week
that they did their quick snap
impeachment and i do think if this is
the standard we must apply it to
everybody else
is that going to be part of the defense
i hope so
yeah i think you'll see uh statements by
politicians
that are more insightful than what
president trump said but when the
founders created impeachment
for the president it was different than
for judges
and anybody else it requires the chief
justice of the united states
to preside over presidential
impeachments why because you don't want
a juror presiding over the impeachment
of a presidential office holder so the
idea
that the president is treated deep
differently under the constitution
makes perfect sense they never envision
going after president once he's out of
office
because the purpose of impeachment is to
remove the person not bar them from
running
in the future so the whole point of
impeachment is lost
when the person is no longer in office
they didn't go after nixon when he
resigned for a reason
so to my colleagues here you're about to
set in motion
and historical precedent that will put
at risk every future president
you could be impeached in the future
based on hatred
50 hours no witness no hearing no lawyer
you could be impeached after you leave
office
george washington under this theory
could be impeached for awning slaves
we're doing a lot of damage to the
country because people hate trump
knocking p can we impeach senators can
we impeach the sitting vice president
the sitting president
over insurrection charges based on their
own words
there is no limit to what they're doing
they're setting in motion something
that is basically political retribution
it's not based on facts
they actually impeach the president for
the gathered defects
we're finding things now that would be
crucial to his defense he never had a
chance to make a defense in the house
all right lindsey graham we'll be we'll
be watching and unfortunately
they don't pay you enough to have to sit
through that shift show